- [Interviewer] All right, Dymond.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] Hi, Dymond.
Where'd you grow up, Dymond?
- I grew up in between 30th,
34th streets in King,
And I also stayed in
the Vermont Knolls area.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so
now you're in South Central?
- Yes, I'm back in the
Vermont Knolls area.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And
tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents?
- No, my dad, he was
incarcerated for eight years.
He went to jail when
I was eight years old,
and he got out when I was 16.
Well, as a kid, I think
I was the youngest child,
and I was very active.
I think I'm my mom's problem child.
A lot of people say I'm different.
And you know, so as a
kid, I was growing up,
I went to a residential home in Utah.
I was put away because I was like 12, 11.
I started running the streets.
I started like gang-banging,
hanging out, doing drugs.
And I started surrounding
myself with people
that didn't really didn't
have my best interest in.
Then I just developed like a lifestyle,
something, a habit.
And it's just something
that I've just been doing ever since.
- [Interviewer] What age did this start?
- I mean, like when it comes
to me acting out and stuff,
you know, I was always put away.
I probably was like eight acting out.
But like, when I started
running away, I was like 10, 11.
- [Interviewer] And you
started working the streets
at what age?
- Um, eleven.
- [Interviewer] Eleven.
- Yeah.
I was always lying about my age,
everywhere I went.
I went to jail with my cousin one time
and he was like,
"Dang, you know, now
that I think about it,
"you've been 18 for three
years now, you know?"
(chuckling)
But, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you were
working as a prostitute
on Figueroa?
- Yes, Yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] At 11?
- Not at 11 that's the
first time I turned my date.
- [Interviewer] First
time you turned a date was
- (overlapping) Yes.
- [Interviewer] at what age?
- Cause I stayed like on 51st and Fig',
So, you know, on my way to school,
I went to 51st,
on my way to school,
I was walking down a one-way,
and this truck driver,
I was like 12, maybe 11.
- [Interviewer] 11 or 12?
- Yes.
- So that's, like, what grade?
That's probably
- sixth, seventh.
- [Interviewer] Sixth
grade, something like that?
- Um-hm.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember that first time?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What was it?
Was that the first time you had had sex?
- No it wasn't, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I didn't,
I wasn't really having sex then,
but I had did a sexual favor for the man.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
Was there any abuse or anything like that
in your childhood,
when you were younger?
- Yes.
I was touched by a cousin of mine
and I never really told,
because, like, I was made
out to be the promiscuous
one, or, you know,
I never really said anything.
And then like,
I didn't put myself in situations to where
I was very vulnerable to men,
And I felt like,
like it's rape, you know, it's rape.
When you don't want to
have to do something,
but somebody making you feel like it
because you're uncomfortable.
I've been put in a lot of
those situations, you know?
- [Interviewer] You were working
with a pimp at that age?
- Um...I... no.
I met this guy
when I was 15 years old,
and I started dating
with him, or whatever,
And he was a pimp,
but he was also selling drugs too,
But he ended up dying.
- [Interviewer] Hm.
Have you been arrested for this before?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Never been arrested?
No.
- [Interviewer] Have you been roughed up,
and had bad experiences
with some of the customers?
- Yes, I have.
I've been cheated,
and it,
it fucking sucks.
That's why I don't like,
like working the streets,
I'd rather work the web.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, So
you do it through calls
- (Overlapping) The web. Yeah.
[Interviewer] and stuff like that.
- Um-hm.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
encounter guys that are
problems?
That are trouble?
- I mean, not so much like of,
there's just you more have
to watch out for the feds.
You know?
- [Interviewer] Oh.
So it's almost the same game,
Just you're doing it online,
instead of on the street?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- No.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- 25.
- [Interviewer] You're 25?
- I...
- [Interviewer] Your dad
was in prison for what?
- He had,
I don't remember.
He was, I was, I was eight years old,
but I think it was like robbery,
but you know he already was like,
he already been to jail before,
but they just held him this long time,
Cause he violated his probation.
He went for nine years.
He got out March 5th,
March 4th, 2009,
And I got out March 5th, 2009.
And I came from my residential home
in Utah,
and ever since then,
I've just been running the streets.
Like, you know,
it's just become a way to
I don't see myself doing
nothing else sometimes.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- [Dymond] Almost.
- [Interviewer] How much money do you make
in a night?
or a day?
- [Dymond] It depends.
Like, cause you know, I
spend it as I go, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Dymond] So it depends,
like I be touching like...
Man, I be touching like
on a slow day, like
maybe like 600, 700.
on a good day,
Maybe... it depends.
It, it varies.
It really varies.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know you do this?
- [Dymond] I try not to tell them,
but I know they have a good idea.
- [Interviewer] Does it
get you down sometimes?
you get depressed sometimes?
- [Dymond] Yes, yes, yes.
Yes. Cause I just,
I just be wanting to have someone,
you know, to talk to,
but I've find to get along
with the voices in my head now,
because,
like, it's hard to explain
somebody your lifestyle,
or like what you think,
or, I don't know,
like, just what I be going through.
It's hard to explain that to somebody
and not get the
not saying I want to
hear a certain answer,
but it's always like criticism
coming along, you know?
I don't, I don't know.
I don't know.
Like, I don't know how to explain it,
but I'm not trying to have
no pity party for myself,
but people don't know until
they really come here.
You know?
Like, you just get treated different.
- [Interviewer] How about
your cigarette (indistinct).
- Thank you.
(lighter flicks)
- [Interviewer] What's the
hardest part of doing this
for a living?
- Once you start, you can't stop.
And no matter how you
no matter how you try to play it out,
you always come across something.
It's like, it's like, not like,
it's like, it's like a scent
on you or something wherever you go.
Like it's just going to always follow you.
- [Interviewer] It's like an addiction?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What do you think the
most misunderstood thing is
about that other people
don't quite understand what
what goes on for you guys?
- Well, because a lot of when it comes
from the women,
stereotypically me, you
know, I'm the scale.
I'll say it's because there is probably
there are men that'd be paying for it,
And they, they like to like make that down
because the way we dress,
or you know it's,
but you know, that's the business.
That's what sells, you know?
So I think people,
I mean it's,
if it was easy to get a job
this is just easy just to walk
to the corner and catch a date.
I will have one.
I will have three.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's, it's hard.
Like, it's like,
at least you're not at
this point, you know?
At least you found,
Cause once you, like, get
in, it's hard to get out,
because it's something that
you become accustomed to.
- [Interviewer] You been in love before?
- I'm only 25.
(Dymond giggles)
I have.
why you asked?
- [Interviewer] No I just
wonder if this lifestyle kind of
makes it difficult.
For my love life?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Ooh, that's crazy you said that.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] It must be, right?
- Yes.
[Interviewer] If you and I were dating,
- [Interviewer] and you were
seeing five guys at tonight,
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] it would
be difficult for me.
- Yes. Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] and for you.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] You think you're happy?
- Am I happy?
- [Interviewer] Are you a happy person?
- I'm a happy person.
Yes, I have,
I have, yes.
I'm a happy person.
I don't try to be miserable,
but, like happy,
Like, I see stuff and
I be feeling bad a lot,
but happy?
I'm a happy person.
I'm not miserable.
I be happy with myself.
- [Interviewer] What advice would you give
to a young girl,
Who's thinking about doing
something like what you do?
- Um.
Um um um.
Always try to keep something
going for yourself.
Always, at the end of the
day, have your best interests,
and everything to the eye
that's intriguing, is not
to, to your, to your lifestyle.
Like, don't be,
Don't be so quick to,
to try to be in just,
and I mean,
really just find morals,
and what it's like,
like I don't know how to explain it.
Just find the morals of things,
the values of things,
or, you know?
But just always try to
keep something going,
and try to invent something,
try to come up with some
of the newest something,
or you know, try to stay ahead like that.
Like, the other stuff
is like really, like,
I don't know.
it'd be cool for them,
but as, as you go in the,
the men, you know, like, I don't know,
just I will, I would really,
if I could start all over again,
I would be slow
into talking to men,
and slow into believing men,
and I kind of would
change the crowd of me.
- [Interviewer] Do you think doing this --
- Be particular about
who you surround yourself
with, because at the end of the day,
that's who you become.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
doing this all these years has
changed the way you view men?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Because the
guys you're meeting over
and over again are --
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] probably a different --
- [Interviewer] thought than...
- Because, it'd be like, it's
to where it's hard to like,
it's just my certain ways that I am that,
in my relationship, my
guy, he doesn't like it.
He says it,
and I know he's not
lying because it's true.
Like, why would you say
some stuff like that?
You know?
And I don't try to let him
know my business on that,
but I don't lie about it,
but I don't try to like
be brief with him about it.
But that's the problem
in the back of his head.
I know it is.
- [Interviewer] How do
you think doing this
since you were a young
teenager has changed you?
- Man, I, I don't,
- [Interviewer] It's all you've ever done.
I, I just, that's what, I
it's like a job of mine,
so I just do it.
That's how I survive.
And in order to do it, I
got to run the streets,
and sometimes in order to run the streets,
I have to do drugs, you know?
- [Interviewer] Are
drugs part of the picture
for you?
- It can be at times.
Well, I like marijuana
and pills.
- [Interviewer] All right, Dymond,
thank you so much for talking
with me,
and good luck,
- [Dymond] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] with
the rest of your life.
You're still young.
- [Dymond] Yes, I am.